hey guys what's up it's Justine and
today we've got something pretty
exciting I know that I say every time I
lock something is exciting because
usually it is exciting but this
particularly is super exciting and I
can't even tell you how many of you guys
have tweeted me sent me messages
comments to get these cases these are
iPhone cases to replicate the old-school
iMac colors there's also this one which
is the classic original iPhone which I
have one right here I have a bunch of
videos coming out with this I have an
iPhone 10 verse original iPhone video I
also have one showing you guys how I
managed to get this thing to work those
will be out after WTC but in the
meantime here it is it's beautiful
it's working and I'm so happy about it
and now I have an iPhone 10 case to
match this isn't a sponsored video but
they did send me these to check out
because I went to the website and they
weren't available yet so thank you guys
for getting me an early look for getting
us an early look and thank you to you
guys for sending me this as a suggestion
because these are so cool also the iMac
has a very special place in my heart it
was one of the first computers that I
got for my grandmother so I went there
with her to get it and she got the lime
green one if you guys don't know shout
out to my grandmother because she is so
tech savvy like you guys don't even
understand I know I've showed you guys
those before of every holiday my grandma
makes me a really cool book of my pastor
adventures it's so cool I get to go back
and look at all of the cool things that
have done and it's awesome because my
grandmother has made these for me and
it's so awesome so thank you grandma I
love you I miss you and do you remember
the lime green Mac I'm pretty sure she
still has it anyway tangent let's open
this up look at this stuff isn't it neat
wouldn't you think my collections
complete spigen commemorates its tenth
anniversary by introducing this
limited-edition case inspired by the
original iPhone I'm just gonna jam it in
there jamming it in there is definitely
not in the directions there are specific
installation instructions right here and
here it is the original iPhone case
let's see what it looks like next to the
original iPhone it is a little bit
bigger it's a little bit taller
okay looks pretty good that's that's
pretty dead-on I think that's gonna be
my WWDC look for sure so what if I take
a picture of myself with
the original iPhone with the original
iPhone case on my iPhone 10 is that what
does that mean
that's a weird inception right there
well let's take a look at some of the
other cases because we've definitely got
a couple more to take a look at as I was
editing this video I realized I kept
messing up the names of the colors I
didn't realize there were so many
variations throughout the years I found
this handy little color chart so moving
forward these are the proper names and
the colors and year that the iMacs were
released here's a commercial for the
iMac graphite standard built-in DVD
player it's a thing so we have the
graphite we have the line we have the
strawberry it really is crazy how
quickly technology has changed open the
recipes up so good look I can't believe
how awesome this look it's crazy because
the phones that we're using now are
almost more powerful than the computers
that we're using back then there's the
graphite one I love that this inside
case it says hello again if you guys
remember the I guess it's essentially
like the tagline or the slogan for the
imax was hello it was basically like a
reintroduction for Apple these imax
really helped apples step back into the
spotlight it reinvented them as a
company where did my phone go here it is
I'm trying to decide which case I'm
gonna wear for WWDC I'm thinking I might
wear this one because it is kind of a
really cool retro throwback to the
original iPhone I'm so excited for you
guys to see the videos that I've been
shooting with it so let's pop this off
and take a look at one of these other
cases they look like these look so great
like I just I want to wear them all but
I can't wear them all at the same time I
care more about my iPhone cases than I
do about what I'm actually wearing in
real life clearly that's not new
information to anything you've been
following me for a while these just snap
the bottom off pop that back in you can
still see the Apple logo through a
little cutout there I don't even know
which one is my favorite I think it a
graphite could be it's a nice subtle
look let's try on another one these
cases are a little difficult to get off
it's not just these cases I feel like
all iPhone cases are sometimes a
struggle this is gonna look so great
pushed so many buttons and taken so many
screenshots by accident Wow signing
shimmering splendid so here's all the
cases they should be available really
soon which ones are your favorite colors
have any of you guys had these original
Macs
I feel like we had and he was like the
Snow White want that wasn't a part of
the original ones
oh it was gone the eMac I'm having so
many flashbacks I feel like one of these
days I have to do a history of my Apple
usage so I'll go through a timeline of
when I started to where we are now it
really is crazy thinking back to all
over the computers that my family did
have throughout the years we've always
been an Apple family because my mom was
a teacher so back then most teachers or
people in education they offered
educational discounts so usually most of
the people who had apples were in the
education system so it's very very lucky
to have always had Apple computers in
our family I've almost any pictures of
one of our old computers is one of the
Macs it was the new one megabyte version
but I do have a very fun surprise for
you guys coming up also sort of a
somewhat soon I've been doing a lot of
eBay recently so I've got some fun
vintage videos coming out for you and
it's been so much fun to sort of see
where things have sort of started not
necessarily start it started but started
for me in the sense of what was the
computer out when I was born you guys
know when I was born you know exactly
what the computer is that I'm talking
about so it's I get really emotional
when I'm talking about this stuff I'm
not really sure why but it's I can't
control how I feel it's how I am call me
dramatic you wouldn't be far off such a
tangent
stay tuned cuz I've got some fun things
for you guys these cases are awesome
thank you guys so much for suggesting
for me to check these out they will be
out very soon I think this is what I'll
be wearing to WGC make sure you guys are
following me on Twitter and Instagram
because I'll be posting tons of updates
from WWDC also make sure you are
subscribed to my youtube channel and be
sure to hit the bell so you guys will
get notifications when I post a new
video because I may be doing a few live
streams from there as well and you do
not want to miss it alright guys I'll
see you in my next video I'm going to
put these all back in their boxes
because they're beautiful and they need
to be preserved just for so I figured
later
no I come here a little you know boy or
girl am i doing a Reebok thing right now
is that a thing I mean I feel like it
should be a thing hey guys welcome to my
first Reebok Singh you know what can I
say
[Music]